a topic is titled overview of quantum
capacitive lattice systems but what I'm
actually going to say is about crypt
analysis or hardness of SVP so we've
just heard that all interesting all
cryptographically interesting problems
like seasonably they they are so if it
can break those you can you can solve
some heart problems mitosis and the
relevant question the next relevant
question would be how hard this problem
actually are and it also works another
way around because the way we usually
attacker the bully assist we actually
solve the shortest actor problem so it's
both ways and in both ways it's
interesting to actually see how hard
this this problem is this is an outline
of my talk I'm gonna very briefly again
introduce written it should detect the
problem although you've just heard it
and then I'm gonna focus most of my time
on the quantum sieve the reason I'm
doing it because there are like lots of
this constants floating around to the
previous the previous workshops and I
just want to make them maybe a bit more
understandable and also should emphasize
that I'm gonna keep everything a simple
article I'm not gonna go into details
about pre factors but if you want to do
this you should start from something and
this like perhaps it will be just a
start okay so it mister can fixed
exponential the exponential and the
bonanno's you could try to draw from
from the algorithms alright so this is
my slide about lattices a lattice is a
finely generated discrete subgroup in an
additive and the environment we're gonna
be interested in is I give the
Sanitation system the one will be the
minimum length of the non zero vector in
villages and the good thing about this
one is that we know up
timidly audits what it is so there is a
I mean Koski bond that tells us what
this quantity is about and it's what's
just we care about it's tight for
algorithm that means that we know when
to stop when we found so the there are
basically two ways of to target this
problem two families of algorithms the
ones called enumeration I will briefly
say about this at the end of my talk and
the second one is saving crucial
differences between them is that the
first one is exponential oh sorry
super exponential it's 2 to the n log n
with polynomial memory and the
polynomial memory keeps the same also in
quantum version where the quantum
version of enumeration shapes of a
factor of doing the exponent
so actually if you can improve the cost
of dinner in a spot in a classical
regime you could also improve that
preceding these are the mysterious
constants the mysterious constants are
the 292 time classical time and the 265
for quantum time and the purpose of my
talk is actually explain the nature of
these two constants all right and I
should also say that I'm gonna have to
be focused on every succeeding I think
there was a work done on provable seeing
algorithms but the constants are far
bigger than one classical time and for
quantum I think they're around one
Sakhi what is sitting I'm gonna describe
the very basic ceiling which is called
GUI and Vedic see but it's not the first
algorithm that introduced seeing the
first person to it yes I'm gonna do the
what's called now in GUI and Vedic safe
so the main idea is the following you
have a basis you're given the matches by
a beta so it's a compact representation
and you start sampling Gaussian vectors
from the lattice and you can do that
efficiently as soon as you're not
targeting very short letters immediately
so you can draw Gaussian long vectors in
polynomial time input normal the
dimension and you draw many of them such
many that they appear to live close to
each other and this closest you want to
find you want to detect this closeness
such that the difference becomes shorter
so basically on the picture what I have
is a sample orange vectors I put them
into the list and I want to find pairs
that give me something shorter looks
like this once you find something
shorter you put them in a new list and
then you either in the same process now
what you want to do in probable version
is to actually control that you keep
Gaussian distribution over the whole
lists but arista Clery you usually
assume that whatever we we put it
remains the distribution
you keep this iterating this process by
finding short bursts
and after some at most blue normal many
steps you actually find something shoot
so there are two questions that arise if
you want to analyze this algorithm oh
sorry I want to first make a quick
reference to my previous talk is that
when I spoke about the Kaylee's problem
this is a example of a to this problem
where the your lists your two lists I
give a light on the sphere Y on a sphere
well that because once you sample
gaussians they always concentrate it on
the boundary also on the surface and
without also generality you can assume
that what we sample actually lies on the
unit sphere when you when we when we
normalized it made necessarily be of
course true because we are working with
the lattice and watch it doesn't matter
spoil do not lie directly on the sphere
but if we along with like at the
beginning of the algorithm when we
sample long vectors they will be
approximately the same norm and actually
from the runs from the practical
experiments the lists the vectors we
experience during the runs of the
algorithm via the norm doesn't differ by
much so the assumption that we always
lie on a sphere is not a it's not a very
strong assumption
so then there are two questions that
arise if you want to analyze this
algorithm the first is how large should
we sample originally the vectors how
many vectors definition do we need and
the second is of course what is the time
to find actual to solve this to this
problem
so to analyze this to answer these two
questions what I want to introduce is a
tool that we use to analyze it there are
various tools but I'm gonna present the
one that I find most convenient and
extendable so we're gonna look at
distribution of Graham matrices so just
to recall what the Graham matrix is if
we have K vectors from sphere from a
unit sphere the gram matrix would be
just the K times K symmetric positive
definite matrix that contains the inner
products so you should think about K as
being a small constant for instance to
when we work with two vectors I'll put K
because later we will need caco3 and so
the C is a matrix that contains the
inner products it has one of the
diagonals because we are from the unit
sphere and out of diagonal seiner
products of x and g
so one thing to notice about why this is
a useful notion first of all because the
determine is the two norm of so I mean
imagine I want to sum the two vectors x1
x2 and the sum of x1 plus x2 is
determined by the gram matrix in the
following form if you just open the the
the norm you see that this would be less
a case two it's two times twice the
inner product X 1 X 2
what you can extend it to K now and the
tool that I'm gonna use is a
distribution of these Graham matrices
and the distribution is actually we know
that we know how they're distributed we
know they what distribution they follow
and in particular that's what we used
with Harold in order to analyze a list
version of that is that if you draw a
gram matrix and I will explain in a
second what I mean by that is the the
probability to actually find this this K
vector that follow this distribution
this inner product constraint it's very
close to the determinant of this matrix
to the power and half think about KS
being a constant so it will be around
and and half and also the constant here
we also know we actually have a precise
formula for this for this density
function so this one we can approximate
pretty well so in other words if you
want to find let's say K goes to two
vectors that whose inner product is what
you fix the probability that you find
those on a sphere by random sampling
this
what do I mean by drawing a distribution
about drawing a gram matrix what I mean
by that let's say K equals two that
means I just draw two gaussians with
uniform direction and then I normalize
and that gives me the the C this is very
closely related to what's called the
Wishart distribution except that the
Wishart distribution did not know it
doesn't normalize but this is a known
distribution of K dimensional Gaussian
Joint Distribution of K dimensional
gaussians and the joint I mean X
and if you if you just look at what this
water density function for this
distribution we will actually recover
this formula
this is just the the the tool to use for
the analysis of this ceiling over how to
use that one
well first its it answers the question
how large the edge should be so assume
that at each step we want to find two
vectors that are close that give me this
that who some gives me one so that means
I'm gonna target the I don't target to
do that I'm gonna target this the search
of two vectors whose inner product is
cosine of PI over 3 and the cosine of PI
over 3 is 1/2 so this is my X 1 X 2 and
I'm gonna target the distance 1 in this
sum so this is a triangle with degree 60
angles PI over 3 so this one the inner
product between X 1 and X 2 is the
cosine of PI over 3 is 1/2 so if you
plug that in you will immediately
recover the year the constant for the
list sizes
and so one of the things to notice here
is that because this this probability
density function is exponential in n you
you will notice that all the others
potential in a product configurations
that could also give you one the
exponentially smaller interval bility so
it could happen that you could have some
people's sample some other two vectors
that that give you some that give you
one or something shorter but they
exponentially The probe's that they
appear is exponentially smaller than
that one so you could put any any inner
product constraint inside and see how
many points you need to target not let's
say one but one half one third whatever
by just plugging in into
so that is any way to compute the
computer quietly sizes and if you do a
naive brute a naive search so what do we
do next we find paths into lists into
lists of size that I've just shown well
dieter can do a brute-force search over
the past that would cost you the square
of the list and the square of the list
is this exponent and this is precisely
what appeared in the paper often go and
read it they have the memory of 207 5
and this runtime ok so this is what how
each if one magical exponent the second
exponent that improves this naive brute
force actually uses technique from the
NIV session I'm going to show you this
this techniques and the way we and the
way we can analyze them both
classically at the beginning and then
quantum a okay so what do we do the
technique is for that is called the cut
sent to the filtering so there is the
rest thing that called the concepts in
hashing that uses functions well
filtering do not use functions they use
more so they do not use so filter you
cannot about having functions but rather
having regions and pre images of a
function
so this technique was is actually not
only used for spheres but also for coats
that was first appeared in the work of
my owner of related to the decoding so
not for the angular metric or a Clinton
metric but for having metric and in the
in the area of ceiling it's appeared in
papers by Kadokawa and l'homme until the
16th so the idea is as follows
you forget first about your list at all
your data that you have and you choose
independent vectors independent vectors
on your sphere
which which are called centers so these
centers so you take a point on the
sphere and define and define at the
center of a bowl and let's say the
radius of this ball is alpha you don't
have to cover the whole sphere there can
be some empty holes they can intersect
it doesn't matter much and what you do
next is for all your points in the lists
X I you find all the center's you find
all the use where the X I land so for
instance if if you target X 3 if you
have a if you process X 3 you should put
this into the center or the bucket that
is defined by the center of U 3 and
YouTube
you do this for all of them this is the
this is what is called Encarta sensitive
technique an update phase and the second
phase is what's called the query phase
so there again for all the your vectors
in the list you're gonna you're gonna
ask okay
please show me all the center that lie
within the radius beta and with these
centers give me all the bucket or all
the other points a bucket at the
beginning so and this for this point Q
that will return me the center you three
and the center you three contains X 4
and X 3 and then I check whether these
two also it will return you probably you
four and I'm gonna check against X 1 X 6
and X 10 X 2
I'm gonna check whether I have something
close so without checking all of them
right so I'm gonna only focus on those
that have higher chances to be close to
my query point so that's the whole
purpose
all right so how to analyze this
algorithm this algorithm so the question
is okay there are two questions actually
first you may ask how do I find centers
so I'm giving you a point either in the
update phase or in the query phase and
the question is what how do I find the
relevant relevant points the relevant
centers the relevant you eyes that lie
within the Alpha radius to the 2x from
the rest now there are various now don't
think there are various techniques but
at least one that works is that you do
not choose your you eyes randomly on the
sphere but rather structured and in
particular they should have they should
appear as the that's the idea of the in
the mire of and btj of 16 they are
coming from the product code
so the way you're doing is as follows if
you have an axe and the way to find the
newish which comes from the from a
product code is the first okay decode me
first or the first let's see let's say
small often let's say squared and
coordinates with respect to this code
and this code has length square root and
so that would if it's a random code it
will cost you to do square n could be
the first the first contribution to the
small turn this but it's nothing it's
its square root and would say you've got
all you've got all vectors from this
code that are somewhat close to it x1
then you continue with x2 and then up
until the team this way you can sort of
amortize
they search for the cloak for the
clothes you buy not taking them
uniformly but from the coat and you
exploit the fact that they're from the
coating you have a decoding procedure
so that will probe so that for example
will cost you to do the square root n of
course it should all just notice that it
relies on the fact that we have a so the
second thing to notice is that this is
what was proved in btg else that you the
UI's are not uniform random anymore from
the sphere but that close to being so if
you choose the length of your spherical
coordinate the lengths cannot be like a
constant there won't be a uniform
anymore
but some function of n will suffice
small event small event so if we go to
there now so basically that what tells
you that we can find relevant factors
all relevant centres to a given vector
in time proportional to the donor
question number two what is the time to
so what is the time to update so note
that so recall it for each X we were to
find an element a relevant center that
was an edit at a target distance from it
the time to do that is the number of all
relevant vectors you are going to find
and this time is given to you by total
size of the relevant centers time the
probability that you are an X are a
distance angular distance what is this
probability this is a determinant again
where on the off diagonal coefficients
you put alpha the determinant that would
be precisely this value
exactly the same thing happens for the
query except that we query with some
other parameter query parameter beta
notice that if you want to balance these
two costs you would rather put alpha a
cost a meter base for the classical
version that's what happens and the last
question that remains is how large do
you should be and the way to analyze
this is to ask the following question
I'm giving X 3 and X 4 and I know that
they're sure that they're close to each
other because I've chosen enough of them
at the beginning conditioned on the fact
that they are close how many use what is
the probability that my you will find
them and my you has the distance between
X 3 as alpha and X 4 is beta so what is
the probability that these distances are
from these distances better conditioned
on the fact that these distances is what
I want let's say it's nothing as about
the conditional probability
so this is what I just said so the
number of centers we need is determined
by the inner stability that I actually
find my point and I find my point I mean
the x3 will be will distance I'll find
x4 resistance beta you can change alpha
and better in this case there doesn't
matter which one is I'll find which one
is beta and this is given in particular
by this formula it's a probability
taking over random points on a sphere
that this happens conditioned on the
disability
it's a faction between the probability
that everything happens divided by the
probability that this happens
this is nothing else but the gram matrix
you of the inner products between you X
3 X 4 and the integrand matrix 4 X 3 and
X 4 this is on the Monday night on the
my diagonals there was because they're
all from the sphere this is an inner
product between it you X 3 in a product
in yolks musics for and in a product
between X 3 X 4 and what you do you plug
in C being one half alpha equals beta
and you try to balance the costs with
the with the bucket sizes you actually
do the math in this that's very
difficult to do I just come so you know
all the all the entries here in the
determinant just compute this fraction
and this fraction the inverse of this so
this is the probability right and you
want the inners of that and that will
give you the 303 old
three or two if you put it into the base
door this is precisely the magic tonight
you're such that you catch all pairs of
precisely precisely because for saving
you might do some pairs and that's all
but you're not allowed to is more than
exponential so there's losing losing
paths would mean that you would have to
start with a bit more at the beginning
so to accommodate for your loss and that
would actually that would increase your
that would increase this time because
actually the time unit is for each end
you do that update and the longer the L
is then you increase the update and
hence you increase your Chi query so we
are kind of so right so the times
actually will be the size of eight times
that's the size of L times that so this
value I've just given by is three over
two to the N and if you could i I don't
think that would be an optimal choice to
go
good so yeah this is asymptotical
centers we need to we need to put an
outer sphere to make sure that was the
concert probability no there's a
probability 1 minus exponential small
exponentially small we find all the we
find all the the past we need so we will
be losing something of course because
this is a concentration result it's so
there are some outliers that will always
be there but by channel bounce that we
can also bound them again general bass
increase included may induce another
polynomial factors
I'm practical what can be the quantum we
hear it's not that much do it in the
quantum unfortunately so for the reason
being that we already kind of optimal in
the time of finding all relevant centers
the time of finding all relevant centers
is the same time as as many of them we
have this thing we could try to do
quantum if this is what was done in
theis Jesus and that what we also
extended for a larger case is to
actually go for larger buckets no
because then once we have a bucket once
we are inside the bucket we could apply
quantum Grover's search to actually find
the good one so what we're gonna do so
from the picture from this picture the
quantum algorithm would do the following
on the query queue I'm gonna find
classically all the use the reason why
I'm not doing it quantum is because the
time is optimal already
and I'm gonna create the superposition
of this use very all these vectors X 2 X
1 X 1 a superposition that's why we need
the QRM that's required and I'm gonna do
Grover search over these two vectors and
the grower search would be checking
whether mchugh and this X either are at
the distance that I want this precisely
what they what the quantum version of
Sita's
and if you compare it with the was
classical that would give us alright so
the update time we're gonna change you
change the query time and the query time
would be time to get all the irrelevant
centers classically the same as and the
grover search inside the relevance
inside each relevant Center so if you
want to if if you want the precise stay
that would be as follows would
respond to the following state so first
I'm gonna make a superposition over all
this green is not
I'm going to create a separate position
over all buckets
which are relevant to my ex
I'm gonna query all of those the number
of basically that let's say the size of
the bucket what is the size of the
bucket
and then I do the Grover search of it
the Grover search will cost me so the
citrus I see this this formula is the
number of relevant centers for for a
given X this is this quantity the bucket
size this is this quantity this is the
expect tournament numbers how many times
I need to either eight grow research to
get all of them
and actually we can compute each and
every each and every term from this I've
just shown you how to do that number of
urban centers value for a beta as a
parameter to get the very point the
bucket sizes will be the probability
that for L for each X we get alpha close
this is a number of solution this is our
and you do the the optimal choice of the
parameters and then gives us these
values
so yeah and when people say that maybe
it would cryptanalytic injures are not
that rewarding this is actually true
because we went from 2 9 2 to 265
that's the state-of-the-art without
either awesome tour Chico State oh good
but you could do is you could reduce
both you put in this memory cost first
it doesn't seem plausible with the
current techniques to reduce the
constants for time so you could so for
instance what you could do is you could
reduce the the the constant foot for
time well then it will necessarily cure
the the cost sorry you can reduce the
the memory cost so you could reduce the
the number of vectors you need to go so
you could reduce the value zero seven
five to pretty much whatever you want
but then the time will increase
oh there is no a priori lower bound on
this on the lists on the list sizes so
you could imagine that okay maybe we
should take some to get the parents to
take a face and lower bounds on the list
sizes but actually there is no lower
bound to know this size that feeling
cured time to actually do the search
what else can we do as I just showing
you this quantum version of seif are
actually classical versus a classical
memory sieve it does require a lot of
memory you could do as I said at the
beginning there is another version there
is another way to do to do SVP which is
called enumeration algorithm enumeration
algorithm it does essentially what a
does it traverses a big tree the trees
of size to be up to a constant and
there's been work done on improving this
this ultimately which is called
so-called backtracking technique and the
battery is a legacy
random walk is a quantum random walk on
a tree
the youngest thing you have to make sure
well not the youngest thing but one of
the things you have to make sure for
this particular and the walkers you can
check whether a vertex of your tree or a
path of your trees a dead end or not and
that you can do by just checking the way
the length of the of the vector in a
subspace so that's one thing but then
the other thing you may wonder okay if
I'm actually low-memory Sookie this was
for a sweet pea right so I never I
didn't speak about NWS this problem
because actually the current tech the
way we know how to solve it it's really
bad
in quantum if you don't have if you
don't have enough memory then it could
as well be useful to actually run grover
search just on your saw just a new
search space and asymptotically if your
bind if you vector is binary or sparse
it's unclear to me whether this weather
just grover search over over your secret
would be would not be better than the
so of course it will it will depend on
how sparse your secret is and how big is
Logan so if you really don't want to
target asipi but sees or end a movie
directly it would be a good idea to
actually look what the performance of
the grower search is against I guess
quantum enumeration
another thing I was wondering is whether
we could actually speed up another
algorithms 4lw not SVP but directly
target target lwe one of the other ways
to do it is a biggie W so I spoke
yesterday to Andres about the potential
improvements of biggie double is a
two-step algorithm the first step seems
to be him doesn't seem to be amenable to
quantum speed-up sets because the memory
is equal to this time but there is
second phase which is distinguishing
phase where you have to distinguish
between uniform and Gaussian with a very
small bias apparently there are some
ways to do it one to me faster so you
could maybe play with constants or
sympathetics will not change but
constants may
so I hope Moses will became a little bit
more clear and
so I want to just say that these are
some practical results in practice or if
you really want to to to set up the
parameters you should be should be
careful with with what's what the
algorithm is hide and be go in in
smaller what this is also not RIBA
waiting to actually send those if you
have any questions
[Applause]
it's very much music great presentation
more questions
research what what kind of our code will
have access to so I assume I have an
elderly sample and I'm going to search
for whether my secret is good or not no
I mean Oracle is just and giving it
classical aw samples I put a separate
position over all my secrets sparse
secrets if I can
and then the checking function will be
whether this s is good or not by
checking whether this what are basically
this version B minus a s candidate right
and you know that if my s is wrong it
will be a uniform at Q and if my ass is
the right one that will be really
grouchy I can distinguish those
their questions oh thanks and we'll
regroup at 11:00 a.m. with the second
half of the morning session thanks again